we keep hearing about how banks are
encouraging and efforting to increase
the number of senior-level women but the
numbers indicate that this is just not
happening we have enough women
graduating as MVAs you have banks that
now offer diversity Chiefs affinity
groups parent leave return to work
programs lean in circles what isn't
being done well basically from my
opinion I think the primary challenge
and what's not being done is that we
need to get more male leaders engaged in
the process they need to make sure that
diversity is a business imperative it's
not just that they'll pay lip service
they have to hold all leaders male and
female leaders accountable they have to
make sure they are measured against a
specific target and that they're paid
against that target ms bruise is that I
guess one of the ironies of this perhaps
that some of the men some of them in
position of power in the c-suite they
don't feel that they have a role to play
here and in fact they do absolutely I
think it's a combination of women have
created some women's groups and have
inadvertently excluded men and men
haven't reached out as much to
participate in the dialogue and to have
a discussion all right now I'm sorry go
no no until we get to that point if you
are a mid-level woman in a bank right
now and you don't see a path forward to
the c-suite or to the upper levels
should you be considering lateral moves
that will at least expand your range of
experience even though that might be
something that holds you back later on
lateral moves in my opinion are a good
idea if it helps you get an additional
skill set particularly if you get P&L
experience because one of the challenges
is most senior level jobs require you to
have pnl experience and many women
traditionally haven't had that so if
you're making a lot of remove but it's
gonna get you the P&L long-term I
believe that's a very sound strategy if
you're making a lateral move and it's
just doing more of the same I would
discourage it ms Bruce you speak to a
lot of women
finance and on Wall Street on a regular
basis what are they telling you what are
their concerns I guess the biggest
concern is that the corporation itself
isn't in a position to help them succeed
a good analogy that I use is that
corporations have planted many trees in
the form of attracting and identifying
high potential women but the
organization or the forest is choking
the tree and making it difficult for
women to thrive so we need to figure out
a way to better deal with the
unconscious cultural biases otherwise
women will continue to leave and they'll
do their own startups although go to
other industries such as health care
where they feel that they'll be able to
make more of a meaningful difference and
see success because as you mentioned on
Wall Street there's a lack of mentor
there's a lack of role models there's a
lack of sponsors until some of these
issues are addressed unfortunately I
believe very talented senior women will
continue to leave the street Marianne
you have more than three decades worth
of Wall Street Experience who've worked
at a variety of Wall Street firms
oppenheimer aquila evergreen can you
share with us why you decided to leave
Wall Street I left because there was a
large corporate restructuring there was
an acquisition and as a result of the
restructuring my position was eliminated
I was given another opportunity to stay
at the organization but it was not at
the same size and scope of what I was
used to and I didn't really feel it took
advantage of my board skill set so I
decided to leave and I was going to
pursue other opportunities and then
there were just some medical issues with
my daughter that I had to deal with and
ultimately I decided to do a complete
shift and focus on board